hi my name is david fear i am the film
editor and a critic at rolling stone
and uh we are here talking to the
director felipe
and the producer delfin joker of knight
of the kings
um this is an absolutely wonderful
beautiful film i
love the scene that we're talking about
in particular first off where did you
guys shoot this
hello thank you for this invitation uh
my name is philipp blackard we shot this
sequence
at bassam granbasan it's uh
near abigail one hour by car from abijah
and it was the first uh
the first city of ivory coast be during
colonization
foreign
foreign
[Music]
here
m
[Music]
foreign
tv
[Music]
just
uh let's talk about the visual look of
the scene it is absolutely
beautiful um what was the discussion you
had with your cinematographer
in terms of setting up the lighting in
the mood for this and and how did you
capture that blood red
moon it's absolutely beautiful yeah this
red bull is special effects but
we decided we decided before first i
would like to say that uh
this sequence is uh maybe the middle of
the film
yeah and and it's uh for me it's uh
it's a it's a it's a sequence who chants
everything in the film because we are we
are we have a roma
our narrator our young narrator we
arrive in this prison
and uh blackbird uh the chief of this
prison decided that
he he will tell a story and uh uh
i want it i want it in the script i
discuss with delfin jacket
my producer who is also my artistic
collaborator
we we wanted a second
together between uh
romo and blackbird yeah
and and and we decided to put this
sequence
after when when blackbird is uh he's uh
he's very very he's very sick when he
he when he he lost his uh
his partner kobe and he is in in his
in his cell in his room we we decided
that it was the best moment
to have this confrontation between romo
and blackbird it's a very pivotal moment
in the
narrative and you're right i feel like
it it changes the story and it's a great
entry into the second half in which
things begin to get uh the style and
tone of the film changes i feel
drastically in that second half but
but setting up this scene let's talk a
little bit about the look of it what was
the discussion you had with your
lighting crew with your camera crew with
your cinema photographer your production
design
to get that specific sort of midnight
look to it
i just i discussed with my gop with my
cinematographer toby marie robitaille
and also with my set designer samuel
teser
and uh and also in sound mix
because i i decided that the the
the cell the room of blackbird was uh
at the end of the of the building in
in this cruise on and was very near the
forest
so i i decided to to to
to work uh to to to
works with sound uh it it's
it's just it's a only place during the
film who is not realistic
sounds are not realistic you can add
animals you can add
water some water and i i wanted to
to to to keep the feeling that blackbird
is
already in the way of his death
my sound i wanted to organize this and
with light i decided to i decided to
make a big contrast
because you have this contrast in there
in their bodies
you have a black bird who is very strong
and you have a homo
with a young boy like this and we we
we knew we knew blackbird first so it
was
it was not useful to have his face
but more his uh his figure his
silhouette
yeah by by it's it's by
in this direction we decided to to work
with light
you know your film blends this really
wonderful it's almost like a documentary
style
realism with what becomes this
incredible creative imaginative
expressionism especially in the second
half of the film
so how did that tension play out when
you were doing the scene
knowing that you had to sort of like you
said make it
make blackbeard realize he's beginning
to sort of transition into his death
to add those other elements in and yet
still
keep it in that prison cell really to
keep people in that place and immerse
them in that
that culture i think um
actually i think this is what philip
knows how to do is that you have this
very
real prison and also
this very fictional story and situation
and i think that you can see it in this
scene but also
in many other scenes of the film and
um i i don't know what
what else to say about your question but
i think it he works like this he
works with this very like documentaries
elements
that's very natural to put in because
it's like he's making the real thing and
then he has this
fantastic and bigger than life also
characters and the two
to mix together i don't know how
and we get this for for me it was
it was important to to show the real
violence in this scene in this scene in
this sequence
because at the beginning we
we think that the violence is physical
but the violence is not physical the
violence is a is a
is a it's it's an absurdity
a black black bird decided that he would
he will die and he wanted to kill
someone
yeah and we can we can feel it in the
sin uh
it's not about it's not about a
tradition it's not about just
stories he wants blood before
his death and at this moment
you you can feel that he's completely
crazy
yeah the origins of this story you heard
about this from a friend of yours who
had been
been in prison i guess i don't know if
it was maca but who had told you about
the tradition of the roman right
yeah i met a childhood friend who was in
la maca
and he told me there is this tradition
of omar but
what i want to say so it's a true story
of course they don't kill they don't
kill him
but it's a true story but for
for a black bird i used a personal story
because blackbird is
it's a name of a friend of a childhood
friend
who is dead in this prison
yeah and uh when one black bird tell his
story
as a young boy who who stole uh
she fish it's it's a
it's a real life of the real black bird
his name is his name was bless so i took
i took
the real story the real biography of a
friend
who was a gangster also and i i gave it
to black birds
let's let's talk about the casting and
the actors for a second and your
direction of them
i know some people might know steve
tianchu from les miserables
but bakare kone is a newcomer and he's a
really wonderful find
how did you end up finding him and then
casting both of them in these roles
yes bakarikone is a newcomer we we made
we spent
two with my casting director we spent
two years in abijah
in a different suburb popular suburb to
to make cast and uh to we we met
2 000 young people and we selected 40
40 percent and bakarikone
he came one day like this and i say oh
what
what what do you want to do he said okay
i will see
i will say a poetry from school i say
okay
and he said poetry it was not
wonderful and after this i say okay bye
bye
and he said okay thank you and two
minutes later my casting director
want to see him outside and say come
come on come back come back
and we decided to try another thing with
him and finally
he becomes the main character i i think
something uh
quite special happened with uh
bagarikone
philippe chosing him because
he he felt that he could really
work with him that bakay would listen
because he had never played before and
which is what happened you know he was
really learning and uh
listening to what philip said and i
think that's why because philip had
several choices and finally he said okay
i'm going to choose bakari because i
know he will listen to me
and they rehearse so much you know and
in the end it was great because you know
he is like he
the film is on him in some way and you
know he's also very young and it's the
first time he's
on the screen and he was so calm he was
very calm
all the time and he was really amazing
and i think it's
it's a sort of contract they had
together philip and him about
let's go through this film and and get
to it
and i don't know what other films he's
going to do now
i i don't know i i i saw i saw him today
before
before coming for in this interview
and i want to say that with with a
non-actors
because he is a known actor for me
the director need to have a real feeling
with the with a non-actor it's not
possible because
you you can't use technique so you need
to use another thing
and this is another thing it's a strong
feeling a sort of complicity
between uh bakari kone and me and
it was not with words it was very very
mute
very side in silence but
we will agree on something to to
to go at the end of this film
he's incredibly charismatic and yet you
also have to believe that
as uh blackbeard says he is a he is a
man who deserves to be condemned
uh let's talk about the specific
direction you may have given these
actors for this scene because
uh as you said it's a very pivotal
moment and the two of them really have
to be
communicating with each other how many
times did you walk them through this
what did you tell them going into this
this scene was special because when we
arrived
on the set there was
there was nothing in the room
wow okay so yeah because uh
because of the coup our our
set crew was not operational at this
moment
and the room was empty so all all
uh all the technician customer
assistant director the producer
everybody started to
to to organize something so we spent
two hours for this wow you know
in our shooting time and after this we
decided to
to shoot something
[Laughter]
yeah and uh and and and at this moment
uh for me what it was very important to
have a blackbird
very very sick very
very very loud i would say
yeah to have difficulties to to to to
to in his bed and uh i wanted to
to start with bakari connect with roma
i want i wanted i started to to give him
more strength because for the first time
he he could ask a question to blackbird
to say
why do you you don't stop this game
so progressively i
i i wanted to show him more more
more song more strong and and what what
it was funny for me to to to say
in this sequence
they will tell they will tell the story
they will tell a story to omar because
roman is
the man who tells stories so at this
moment
he will hear the story it's almost like
blackbeard is giving him his power he's
like a wounded lion
and uh he seems to be giving this power
to the roman which really informs the
whole second half of the film
yes he gave his power but we can see in
this sequence also that
blackbird has a has a big projection in
romo as a it's like uh
he sees roman as uh when he when he see
roman
he think about when he was young he
wanted to be
a young a young roma young younger than
roman or stronger than omar
he wanted to be this boy but it's not
it's not possible
and and he has a sort of complicity
because it's a
it's a sort of duo they are against but
they are also a duo
what we can see in this segment it's
it's for this i ask them to move
to move to change a different side
yeah because you you you feel that uh
black a roman could be black bird and
black bird could be homo
and uh uh there is a sort of mirror
a mirror and i i play with a third
a third side with alph mud
who is the man who will observe
everything
from the corridor because he is very
jealous
because he is a lieutenant of blackbird
and never blackbird spoke like this with
him
never blackbird told his life his
his childhood to alfmard so
he observed everything and he said oh
the complicity is not is not a part of
this compensator
delphine let's talk a little bit about
the production design if you don't mind
at what point did this happen in the
shoot was this pretty early on was this
a little bit later in the
in the production actually was uh at the
beginning of the shooting
and uh the prison that we that
the prison lameca that you can see in
the film was shot
in two different uh sets
so there was like the the collective
room
like the big corrective space that you
see where
roman tells a story which is shot in
a department store and this scene has is
shot in
an empty hotel but i
remember as i remember this scene in
particular
because it was because uh
steve is some of uh in french we say
crepuscule
it's like a dawn you know like he's
dying and he's like
has his dawn thing that he's going down
and it's i remember it was really the
the scene that
we said okay things are coming you know
it was it was he was very good in this
scene and you know he was that he was
dying and could feel something very
strong in the scene and that
people were getting together around
i i remember very well this this night
of shooting
it's it's such a beautifully done
steamer and such a wonderful movie i
love the way you mix the prison drama
and uh uh the west african great culture
and dance
and the fairy tale elements it's it's
really beautiful thank you so much for
the movie
thank you thank you